[Musique]
alors que vendredi soir la cérémonie des
césar et sa maîtresse de cérémonie
marina foïs ont tapé sans retenue son
roselyne bachelot et son incapacité à
faire rouvrir les salles du cinéma et de
théâtre c'est comme avoir une
pharmacienne à la culture en pleine
pandémie
voilà que c'est aujourd'hui la ministre
de la culture qui tape sur les césar
dans une interview accordée à rtl la
ministre en est donné à coeur joie pour
flinguer cette cérémonie
cette cérémonie n'a pas été utile au
cinéma français avant d'enchaîner en
tirant à boulet rouge
c'est navrant de voir des artistes
piétiner leur outil de travail à midi
s'est également étonné de la façon dont
corinne masiero s'est mise à nu pour
défendre la culture et s'en prendre au
gouvernement
j'ai reçu des centaines de messages avec
des gens qui me disaient on a eu honte
ce terrible alors roselyne bachelot at
elle eu raison de taper sur les césar
roselyne bachelot at elle eu raison de
taper sur les césars qui pensent que oui
oui moi je trouve ça très bien qu'elle
donne son avis en plus honnêtement j'ai
vu très peu d'articles positif sur les
césars dont je pense que tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus on dit souvent
que les politiques font la langue de
bois on leur reproche mais elle dit ce
qu'elle pense donc je trouve ça très
bien alors c'est vrai que c'est fait
tacler toute la soirée il ya aussi
roselyne bachelot vous si vous avez un
truc que vous avez regardé les césars ou
pas ben oui oui on peut pas jusqu'au
bout
ah mais j'ai regardé mes mais pourquoi
pas jusqu'au bout c'est bien rebondir
parce que non non pas parce que je vais
vous avez fait à peu près hier je vous
ai regardé le tour de la question mon
avis en tant qu'artiste c'est que c'est
pas de notre métier c'est pas le reflet
de ce qu on s est pas le reflet de ce
qu'on pense
je pense qu'aujourd'hui quand on en fait
on a deux on a on n'a qu'un seul
objectif quand on commence ce métier
c'est de faire rêver alors avec ses
atouts certains c'est par leur physique
d'autres c'est par leur tenue d'autres
c'est par le rire mais en tout cas on
n'a qu'une mission c'est celle là et on
nous répète et roselyne bachelot en fait
partie parce qu'elle défend
quoi qu'on dise quoi qu'on fasse elle
défend la culture et on dit qu'on est là
pour être essentiel et ce qu'on a vu
samedi soir c'était tout sauf essentiel
et je crois que les gens en ont
ras-le-bol surtout dans cette période
d'avoir des leçons de morale pour nous
explique comment il faut penser
politiquement comment il faut penser
danse de retenue
on nous explique en permanence qu'il
faut dire est ce qu'il faut faire et là
c'est pas la mission ni des acteurs ni
des actrices
s'il avait dû avoir une carrière
politique ça se serait souvent ils sont
pas très doué quand il l'exprimé je fais
partie de ceux là je me mets pas en
dehors qu'on donne son avis qu'on fasse
pas l'assiette surtout les
qui nous entourent c'est plutôt bien il
faut donner son avis de temps en temps
mais il ya une mission qui était celle
de faire rêver les gens et de leur dire
regardez comme vous nous manquez est
regardé comme on vous manque et là je
crois que ce qu'on a vu
ça fait pas du tout du tout du tout
envie et moi quand j'étais môme mon
frère moi tous mes copains quand on
regardait les césar et convoyait montand
signoret belmondo delon romy schneider
11e mon dieu ce que j'aimerais être avec
eux ce que j'aimerais faire partie de ce
monde là alors que jean denis sort
aujourd'hui si les marchés se rendent
vers les aaa